mon petit effet
comment ça va j'ai pas mis le nez on le
néant même si l escalier ya quand même
année on derrière comment est ce que
vous allez j'espère que ça roule pour
vous que ça roule chez vous que tout va
bien alors on danse par les douanes
place on va se parler du one plus one
pluzz quoi de plus disent tu es nouveau
smartphone alors je vous explique un peu
l'histoire n'est en fait pas tout de
suite commencer je vais rentrer france
billet en vous disant que je suis un peu
circonspect parce que j'aime beaucoup
cette marque je la trouve super
intéressante et je continue de l'aimer
parce que je continue à trouver quoi une
place des produits intéressants mais là
on sent qu'il ya un truc qui fonctionne
pas trop il ya un truc qui va pas et je
pense que ça vient du fait qu'il ya des
pans de marché en moins ça vient du fait
qu'il ya des choses qui vont moins bien
on a un très joli smartphones mais une
frustre énormément vous explique
[Musique]
alors on y va je vous explique on
commence par l'histoire on commence
directement pas rentrer dans le dur près
je vous montrerai plein de trucs le
packaging la boîte qui est sympa on
restera en place le câblage rouge au
ratio en place est ce que vous
connaissez les smartphones de wayne
place que c'est un truc qui vous parce
que c'est une marque qui vous parle si
c'est une marque qui vous parle vous
comprendrez très facilement de quoi on
va discuter ici c'est à dire que one
love a dû restructurer un peu des choses
notamment ici en europe parce que eh
bien le marché évolue parce qu'ils
auront une place c'était un puis deux
puis quelques produits par an mais pas
plus d'abord un smartphone par an puis
la déclinaison vente et puis ensuite la
gamme north qui arrivait et puis on a vu
qu'il ya de plus en plus de marques plus
non plus de concurrence ça devient très
compliqué wyplosz continue à être la
règle de restructurer les choses ont
toujours très belle proposition basée
sur une fiche technique très forte et
très costaud mais ils se sont du coup
plus rapprochés un peu de au pot ils
sont opposés partie du même groupe b b k
mais ils sont plus rapprochés d'eux au
pot sur beaucoup de choses et bon ça me
pose aucun problème parce que au pot
c'est une très belle marque deux beaux
produits avec beaucoup de r&d derrière
et quand vous aviez un one love et sa
déclinaison en t vous aviez des
smartphones très similaires même s'il y
avait quand même quelques petits
changements qui venait s'opérer et il ya
un truc qui si je ne retrouve pas à qui
tout de suite m'a fait mal c'est écrit
comme ça on voit où mais qu'est ce qui
se passe pour qu il y ait pas d bien
vous savez c'est le petit slider c'est à
dire que en fait si vous regardez la
vidéo du one + 10 pro vous retrouverez
comme sur tous les smartphones de one
place sauf la gamme normes un bouton
pour venir l'allumé un petit slider qui
vous permet de venir switcher entre
sonnerie vibreur et on désactive tout
c'est un pitre qui accueille une place
qui fait ça qui faisait ça et là on l'a
pas plus les boutons de volume de notre
côté donc jusque là on se dirait mais
attendre monsieur qu'est ce que tu nous
racontes ce n'est pas très grave non
bien sûr que non mais il ya une petite
perte d'identité là dessus alors est ce
que la marque se dit bon écoute les
parts de marché c'est quand même
compliqué compliqué ce petit slider ils
nous coûtent cher à venir mettre parce
que forcément il faut venir des coupes
et il faut venir le rajouter c'est un
petit truc en plus il ya un peu
d'électronique ça nous coûte cher si on
le met pas est-ce que ça va vraiment
changer la donne la réponse est
probablement non mais quand on est
technophiles qu'on aime la marque qu'on
aime cet univers du smartphone et qu'on
ne voit pas ça et bien on se dit ah ces
annonces y apporte quelque chose et
c'est un peu problématique et sa ccc
pour moi c'est très révélateur ce petit
détail le fait qu'on l'ait pas ici que
c'est révélateur du fait que un peu plus
compliqué pour vannes place parce que
bien qu'ils aient de super produit c'est
compliqué d'être présent sur le marché
et une fois de plus de dettes la
d'exister et il faut faire des choix et
il faut faire attention maîtriser ses
coûts maîtrisés ses marges toujours
hyper évident ça c'est le premier pour
preuve je dis ça parce que j'aime
beaucoup la marque parce que c'est une
marque qui hélas du but quelques très
bonnes années et qui est toujours hyper
sexy et ce smartphone reste toujours
sexy mais pour autant voyez je me dis
est ce que la magie n'opère plus est ce
que la magie disparaît est ce que la
magie change de camp est ce que la magie
est différente j'en sais rien ça reste
un joli smartphones mais ça me frustre
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est à vous l'avez peut-être vu l'année
dernière en 2021 lorsque le one + 9 est
sorti on a eu un partenariat avec castle
blade alors il ya eu un truc un peu
différent on tourne a eu le one + 7 on a
une addition professionnelle 7 et 7 pro
8 et 8 propus déclinaison étaient là par
contre l'année dernière on a eu qu'un
one + 9 et pas de modèle professionnel
et on n'a pas eu une modalité donc un
seul smartphone sorti l'année dernière
et cette année on a eu un mois de plus
dix pros mais on n'a pas eu de veine +10
donc là on se retrouve avec un one + 10
t mais on n'a pas de one + 10 tu es pro
bac je vous ai pas trop perdu donc voyez
on voit camion ne sort pas tous les
produits ils en sortent quelques-uns il
essaye de bien bosser dessus de bien les
marques étaient de bien les distribuer
au pouvoir les vendre c'est comme ça que
ça marche il vit et que ça leur coûte
trop cher d'envoyer tous ses choix
s'opère effet que au bout bien on perd
un peu d' identité de la marque avec un
petit bouton slayer dont au final je
pense tout le monde se fout mais les
gens qui aime moi non plus qui à chaque
fois de plus et bien c'est un petit truc
qui peut manquer on dira il manque ce
truc alors une fois qu'on est passé là
dessus on va rester chez eux ou en plus
on garde la même identité alors ça c'est
l'énorme boîte pour les médias dans
laquelle on vient retrouver bien
évidemment le smartphone qui n'est pas
là dedans qui est dans une poule un peu
plus petit qui est situé là dedans ils
ont mis ici un petit tiroir comme d'hab'
on a montré qu'il y avait des
accessoires whaou j'arrache tout avec
des coques donc si ça vous intéresse of
façon je vous mets les liens dans la
description donc ça c'est plutôt
sympathique lointain une grosse boîte
dans laquelle on vient de retrouver un
bloc de charges alors un bloc de charge
qui est assez marrant parce qu'en fait
votre smartphone il est compatible
charge 150 watts vous rechargez très
rapidement vous lui remettez une grosse
journée de charges en dix minutes
seulement 10 minutes alors après il faut
transporter ce blouson avec vous ça
c'est quand même énorme mais pour autant
vous manquerez jamais rien ça ça pèse
plus lourd que ce smartphone en lui mais
moi je vous dis donc vous le mettez au
fond d'un sac vous faites les épaules
fait le bras faites ce que vous voulez
mais le truc qui est très surprenant
c'est qu'en fait ce bloc de charges sur
un bloc de charge 160 watts qui on vous
le mac c'est la super bowl alors c'est
super vous que c'est pas si ça vous
parle a super books le nom de la
chercher au pot une fois de plus ses
smartphones s'autorise tout doucement et
il ya des choses qu'on vient mutualisés
pour des questions de coûts de r&d ce
dont je vous ai déjà parlé lors on garde
le cordon rouge on garde un design mais
on est sur tech notre charles
propriétaire ou pau superbook mais ça
c'est pas tout nouveau ça ne vient pas
d'arriver c'est déjà le cas par contre
point positif vous avez un bloc de
charles très rapide ici donc s'il vous
rechargez votre smartphone très
rapidement vous pouvez le faire et on le
voit que même le câble lui eh bien voyez
ils se détendent país eu des torts pas
il est pas hyper flexible par rapport à
d'autres petits câbles je pourrais avoir
ça c'est un peu du câble de merde mais
si vous regardez les sections de câble
on n'est pas sur la même chose quoi je
veux dire là on est sur du câble hyper
sérieux et ça bouge pas quoi j'ai
presque l'impression d'avoir un fil de
fer à l'intérieur tellement série gilles
mais bon ça laisse présager de
l'épaisseur du fil pour faire circuler
justement est bien une charge beaucoup
plus costaud bon franchement ça c'est
cool donc une charge très rapide alors
ça leur charge effectivement très
rapidement ça c'est un très bon point en
plus ils ont fait plein de choses
derrière pour venir protéger la charge
et pour pas que ça vient de flinguer
votre batterie donc il ya aussi un côté
qui est extrêmement rassurant ça c'est
bien c'est rapide je me sens très bien
maîtrisée du côté de au pot et de wad
plus fatalement ici au niveau de cette
charge a donc assez bien c'est parfois
quand vous trouvez dans deux couleurs
alors la gelée envers j'aime bien ce
petit verre je trouve très jolie un
petit l'abri en attention qui prend un
peu les traces de doigts mais bon comme
je vous le dis je vous le redis rêve
n'ai pensé à protéger votre smartphone
pour éviter les déconvenues donc bon
comme ça même si vous avez un joli dos
faut quand même venir faire un peu gaffe
et là où on voit aussi le aux côtés au
pot 1 qui est très présent c'est que
vous avez le dos qui est légèrement une
corvée pour remonter par le blog photo
ça me fait penser quand même enfin dit
que cinq provinces a très clairement ce
genre de petits virages qui vient là
alors le module photo pour autant que
c'est bien le module photo signée qu'on
retrouve du côté dieu a oint de plus dix
pros donc bon avec le one + 10 t il ya
une vraie cohérence de gamme j'aime bien
cette couleur il existe également en
noir si vous voulez un truc un petit peu
plus sobre moi comme ça je trouve très
jolie la prise en main est bonne c'est
un grand smartphone attention un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est un peu en
bas quand vous le tenez comme ça et on
vient le chercher comme ça pour venir
déverrouiller c'est le truc qui est un
peu relou bon on s'y fait à la longue
après positionnement du bouton like
plutôt cool vu ça là comme il est
positionné j'aurais préféré avoir un
petit capteur sur la tranche comme ça je
m'en étais pas je prenais part yves de
le faire tomber voile et ses trucs un
peu con ça déverrouille très rapidement
c'est l'optique ça marche bien on a un
écran c'est du flux d'un mot l'aide bon
c'est d'un écran amoled vous avez ici un
taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz alors c'est un smartphone qui
coûte 729 euros à partir de 729 euros je
vous donnais tout les tarifs tout à
l'heure mais il ya un truc qui est un
peu relou je trouve à ce tarif là vous
avez bien taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz regardez c'est écrit ici et
lever 120 hertz mais ce n'est pas de
l'adapt hâtif ça veut dire qu'il va pas
venir changer lui tout seul
automatiquement à faire le boulot donc
soit vous le laissez ans en vacances
tout le temps où ils ont écouté j'ai dû
120 hertz et fluide en permanence même
si j'ai pas besoin de sang versé magique
quand même du sens inverse alors tout en
sachant que ça vient taper un petit peu
dans la batterie de votre smartphone de
100 verte mais bon vous avez ça coûtait
donc bon quelque part ils sont fous un
peu sinon vous tombez en 60 hertz donc
ici va pas faire le switch
intelligemment et automatiquement entre
eux du 90 air du 60 du sang vers s'il ne
fera pas ça à vous de venir le faire
donc c'est que ces trucs qu'on se dit un
peu
relou quand même sur un smartphone comme
celui là de ne pas voir ça à ce prix là
une fois de plus 7 129 euros au delà de
ça je trouve plutôt pas mal on a une
grande diagonale de 6 7 pouces un écran
qui est compatible hd r10 plus un
milliard de couleurs bon voila apres
très très jolie dalle bien maîtrisée ici
donc pas de souci donc si vous voulez
effectivement année des films des séries
vous allez ce qu'il faut on a en plus un
écran qui plaque est plutôt bien fait
alors attendez si on se met comme ça et
qu'on vient dans les paramètres pour
vous voyez il ya aussi un très beau
boulot café parce que je trouve qu'il ya
une très jolie symétrie entre le haut et
le bas vous n'avez pas un grand montons
donc un écran qui est aussi très
joliment intégrer directement ce
smartphone là haut parleurs pas des
lieux il est donc votre part l'aï 6 au
deuxième puis en renfort la et
franchement il a dû songer mis à fond
lorsque je joue à des jeux regarder des
films et des séries ça va voir carrément
un peu de nous à l'histoire regardez
[Applaudissements]
savoir alors celui là il ya un public et
de l'armée c'est normal mais dans
l'ensemble si vous voulez déjà profité
d'une bonne expérience comme ça on voit
du pâté après vous a quand même du
bluetooth 5.2 vous pouvez venir ma paire
et tout ce que vous voulez en termes
d'écouteurs en termes de besoins en
termes de cases plutôt à la cool alors
bien évidemment il n'y a pas de prise
jack ici un héros ni en baisse en outre
à ça aujourd'hui il y en a de moins en
moins et puis on va avoir des codecs du
sbc il a pété x hd on va voir duel
d'aquin vendu assez également alors
maintenant la question qu'on va tous se
poser en choeur tous ensemble j'entends
vous la posez ok c'est bien mais est-ce
que c'est un smartphone qui est
performant la réponse est oui c'est un
très grand vis ça très beau oui et ça ça
reste vraiment dans l'adn de ce café ou
en place depuis des années c'est à dire
proposer une fiche technique surboosté
très booster et la sarre est exactement
la même chose que vous avez aujourd'hui
le meilleur processeur existant sur le
marché ici c'est à dire le stand rigole
8 + jane un qui est très très bien qui
marchent vachement bien qui ne chauffe
pas pour venir jouer à des jeux alors
vous sentir un léger truc mais ça
chauffe pas par rapport aux sabres a
connu huit jane un donc là on est quand
même vachement mieux vous avez soit 8
soit 16 giga de ram la technopole ciel
très très bonnes c'est la lpddr2 5 et
vous avez soit 128 soit 256 go de
stockage en f3 posant vous dire qu'ici
vous avez une formule magique au niveau
de ce triptyque ira très très bien et
qui marchera bien donc un des choses qui
sont plutôt cool tout en sachant qu'ici
on a une batterie de 4800 millan perreur
qui tiendra bien un jour un jour et demi
ça va dépendre de vous de vos usages et
compagnie se recoller l'histoire mais
comme on a ce truc là on est peinards
alors il faut savoir qu'ici il ya une
fois de plus des choix qui ont dû être
arbitré c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas
de recharge sans fil il n'est pas
compatible recharge sans fil et quelques
années c'est un peu l'histoire que nous
raconte ewan place nous eh oui mais nous
on veut pas la merde parce qu'on n'y
crois pas parce que la recharge sans fil
n'est pas assez rapide il nous raconte
cette histoire parce qu'en fait ils
l'intégrer pas et je pense parce qu'il
voulait maîtriser leurs coûts et là ils
sont du bon ben on va la mettre sauf
qu'aujourd'hui sur ce produit là il la
met pas parce que je pense alors qu'août
aussi un peu chaque il faut bien
maîtriser les coûts au maximum pour
augmenter la rentabilité du produit
peut-être évité de perdre de l'argent
j'en sais rien une fois de plus je peux
dans un petit papier en tout cas ça me
semble être assez logique donc ici pas
de charge sans fil donc si vous êtes
accro de la charge sans fil non par
contre si vous avez la charge rapide est
la réponse est oui autre gros point
positif ici qu'on va retrouver c'est
l'expérience logiciel ici on est sur
oxygen os c'est l'expérience android
signée walt place sur l'android 12 da
pour l'instant regarder lorsque je viens
la pop là je veux avoir toute cette
partie là avec la personnalisation que
peut avoir par wang place de l'autre
côté hop j'ai mes paramètres hockey
plutôt bien mon tiroir d'application
bref vous connaissez l'histoire celle
d'android ça marche bien autre sujet qui
est aussi super important c'est toute la
partie de la photo alors vous le voyez
on a trois modules photo à l'arrière un
grand-angle un ultra grand angle et de
la macro ok alors le grand-angle vous
allez voir que c'est un capteur très
standard c'est le capteur haut de gamme
de sony cette année 50 méga pixels c'est
la sony et mick 766 on la retrouve
partout sur le marché ce capteur
aujourd'hui il est dans les hauts de
gamme il est globalement un peu partout
dont vous avez un très joli capteurs
l'ultra grand temps ils ont fait des
choix nous ont mis à 8 mégapixels et
vous allez voir que franchement il
aurait pu s'abstenir offert un peu mieux
bon tels que du soft un avenir un module
est et puis elle a macron 2 mégapixels
c'est vraiment histoire de se marrer on
va regarder le résultat mais vous allez
voir que réellement ici vous avez un
vrai capteurs le reste c'est sans en
mettre d'autres alors vous avez bien
évidemment une caméra de saïfi à l'avant
qui est juste là je te l'avais bien dans
le cadre ça marchera pas on est sûrs en
16 mégapixels tous les plus tendres à
ont pu venir faire de la vidéo j'étais
en 4k 60 images par secondes bon ok
voyez donc non de ce point de vue là y'a
rien de bien surprenant alors regardons
voir ce que ça donne en réalité dans les
photos on va commencer par la nuit on va
se balader les nuits au regarde alors
regardez moi je trouve que dans
l'ensemble c'est pas mauvais j'ai tout
shooté au grand-angle parce que la nuit
l ultra grand-angle ont doublé la macro
qu'on va pas s'amuser à venir souhaiter
à la macro alors je suis pas venu vous
mais parce que mon la photo nuit on va
éviter déconner on reste comme ça et je
trouve que c'est quand même globalement
plutôt pas mal c'est à dire qu'on a des
lumières ici qui sont quand même
vachement bien maîtrisée par
l'algorithme les lumières là là là c'est
très très bien alors c'est toujours un
peu chaud c'est un peu jaune déjà on a
cette perle à paris et puis surtout ses
éclairages qui viennent réchauffer c'est
la nuit rien de bien des conneries mais
ça reste bien maîtrisé voyez même au
niveau de la bouée niveau des contours
on voit bien la branche là moi je trouve
ça pas mal continue et regardez ici
c'est pareil rien à redire ça me va bien
on voit bien aussi les lumières au fond
il a rien qui dégueule bon ça marche
alors ici c'était un peu plus dur avec
cette lumière là bon je pense par
rapport à mon positionnement mais dans
l'ensemble ça me dérange pas la même
chose ici je trouve ça assez joli plutôt
plutôt bien fait c'est très convenable
ça marche vraiment bien pour de la photo
nuit que là c'est pareil parce que j'ai
choisi une lumière au dessus quand je
pense que ça m'a mis un peu le un peu le
bazar ce que je veux dire le reprocher
ça des fois ça vient sursaturé un peu
l'histoire là c'est l'éclairage que vous
avez une place des vosges c'est à dire
que l'éclairage il est coloré et ça vous
tente là tout seul même les cailloux oui
c'est la même chose même la terre ici et
là voyez elle un peu tâté et là c'est
trop saturé donc par moments je le
trouvais qu'il va venir mais saturer un
peu trop histoire et je trouve ça un peu
dommage ça c'est une photo prise à la
main directement on a deux secondes de
pause longue on voit quelques petites
étoiles bon ok là il est posé sur un
trépied là on a dû 30 secondes un d'expo
on voit un peu mieux les étoiles le ciel
est un peu mieux un peu mieux maîtriser
la même chose pour l'ag refaite sur une
pause longue un peu mieux orienter je
trouve ça assez joli quand même dans
l'ensemble ça marche plutôt pas mal la
même chose ici alors là ce n'est pas une
étoile filante ans et un hélicoptère qui
passé pareil ici je trouve ça plutôt
bien fait donc les photos de nuit en
règle générale je trouve bien je trouve
pas un moment un petit peu trop saturé
et c'est ce que je veux dire reprochés
et là c'est pareil sur la photo jo c'est
ce que je viens lui reprocher je la
trouve trop saturé je trouve que le bleu
du ciel est beaucoup trop bleu je trouve
que des fois le verre est un peu trop
vert il ya un côté un peu trop flatteur
et sur la photo comme ça faisait venir
un petit peu ajustées quand même la
saturation sur le grand-angle et l'
ultra grand-angle et là il ya un truc
sais pas si ça vous saute aux yeux mais
l' ultra grand-angle il manque de piqué
mais c'est dingue c'est à dire qu'on a
presque l'impression qui a coté un peu
légèrement flou légèrement voilé et
waouh ça c'est dommage rachou venu nous
sommes un peu x 2 x 5 jusqu'à fois
disent on va pas trop s'y amuser parce
qu'on n'a pas de télé objectifs ici donc
là c'est pareil c'est le grand angle et
ça marche c'est correct comme ça ici
mais là on a l'impression regardez là
que c'est c'est pas net en fait on n'a
pas énormément de piqué et il ya
vraiment ce côté un peu manque de
netteté que je trouve vraiment dommage
là c'est pareil c'est pas mal on a dû
piquer son grand angle dès qu'on passe
sur l'ultra grand temps au nom de zeus
et le bordel absolue et voilà il ya un
vrai manque de piqué là dessus là c'est
pareil jamais reproché un poil trop de
saturation bon c'est pas ce photophone
il fait des choses qui sont assez
correcte sur le grand angle le reste ça
vous le voyez sur l'ultra grand temps
que c'est ta manière que ça c'est pas
mal en termes de gestion des lumières
bien que je lui mets quand même un beau
contre jour là la façade reste très
visible très clairs notre côté ça marche
l'algue au boss quand même plutôt pas
mal mais là la regarder sound a
l'impression que c'est fou parce que
vous le verrez bien au travers de votre
écran comme ça mais on a du mal à lire
et un côté un petit peu floue manque de
piqué il ya un truc à venir reprendre là
c'est pareil c'est la même chose donc
autant la gestion des lumières je la
trouve pas mal autant je trouve que
c'est des fois trop saturé moi j'aime
m'amuser vite fait avec le mode macro on
oublie la macro ici les capteur 2
mégapixels pour faire de la macro c'est
vraiment histoire de se marrer c'est du
marketing pas plus pas moins l'appareil
un capteur grand temps que ça marche
bien l'ultra grand temps gardé le nom là
barnes a l'impression que c'est flou
c'est très étrange et ça c'est vraiment
le truc à oublier et la caméra de
celle-ci bon
c'est pas mal quoi mais histoire de pas
plus pas moins bon bien évidemment on va
avoir du nfc ici alors que donnent les
tarifs config 8 +128 on est à sept cents
9 euros et cs plus de 156 à 829 euros la
question aujourd'hui c'est est ce que
c'est un smartphone que je peux venir
vous recommander si oui à quelle heure
si vous cherchez de la performance si
vous aimez la marque points de plus si
vous aimez le design et vous voulez un
smartphone qui est bien et qui est
performant vous avez un smartphone qui
est bien et qui est performant sur
charges extrêmement rapidement donc si
votre problématique à vous c'est la
performance la puissance il fait de ne
jamais manquer de batterie et bien vous
avez un truc est quand même plutôt pas
mal et ça c'est un bon combo donc si
maintenant vous voulez smartphone avec
un appareil photo polyvalent qui fera de
bonnes photos assez réaliste je pense
pas que ce soit ce smartphone qu'il vous
faille parce que une fois de plus il y
aurait des choses à venir moduler au
niveau de la saturation sur ce capteur
principal sur ce grand temps que je
trouve pas super c'est pas mal sauf si
vous aimez les choses très saturé
ultra-grand-angle aujourd'hui je ne peux
pas leur commande et la macro ben non
mais c'est pas le sol un nom que je pars
à voilà non il n'y a pas de télé
objectifs non plus ici je viens lui
reprocher aussi si vous n'avez pas tout
rafraîchissement variable sur un
smartphone qui est contre 729 euros et
un peu plus de 800 euros c'est un truc
qui aussi un peu problématique
aujourd'hui voyez donc bon ça
smartphones qui est pas mal qui
s'inscrit dans la lignée de ce que fait
wyplosz mais qui n'a pas la saveur de se
dire waouh owa ils ont fait un truc de
dingue et qu'ils ont fait un truc pas
mal voilà ils ont tout qui bien qu'ils
maîtrisaient mais je pense que la
concurrence aujourd'hui à ce tarif là
elle est tellement rude c'est pas le
smartphone qui va faire la différence je
pense pas que c'est le smartphone qui va
aider one plus à venir en vendre
énormément et avoir beaucoup de place
dans les bacs et c'est dommage parce que
c'est une belle marque c'est une belle
histoire mais bon voilà autant j'avais
bien aimé le one + 10 pro temps le bonne
publicité je suis un peu plus mitigé
cochon dans l'inconnu raconte voilà donc
voila mon retour sur ce smartphone dit
comment vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous le trouvez ce que vous
aimez la marque oui non tout ça moi
j'aime la marque je continue à le dire
je continue à croire à la marque je sais
que c'est plus dur pour eux avec peu de
produit aujourd'hui d'exister de pouvoir
être présent maintenant il ya peut-être
des correctifs logiciels qui vont venir
arriver au niveau de la photo c'est
complètement possible au moment où je
fais le test j'ai la dernière mise à
jour voilà je ne peux que constater vous
embrasse pour les soins de vous il ya
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]